espèce de [__] que tu es là espèce de
[__] de partir monsieur faites partir
aujourd'hui faites partie je te dis
allez c'est bon c'est parti
j'ai trop peur fais-toi partir cet
enfant [__]
l'expression
14 on est en direct et nous sommes avec
solovitch Dumas patron du cirque de Rome
comment ça va mon ami ben ça va j'ai
couru pour venir sur le plateau tu m'as
enfin vous m'avez appelé pour venir
aujourd'hui parler parce que parler d'un
problème qui est récurrent ici en France
et je t'en remercie de nous inviter pour
éclaircir un peu ce qui se passe
actuellement dans notre pays parce que
c'est important de le dire je te le dis
parce que il y a plein de gens il y a
tout le monde tombe sur les cirques tout
le monde tombe sur les cires tout le
monde tombe sur les forains tout le
monde tombe sur les gars qui pensent
qu'à une chose c'est aussi bien sûr ils
gagnent leur vie mais aussi ils pensent
à vous amuser à amuser les enfants on
est très content d'aller à sa défaite
foraine d'aller au cirque de dire aux
enfants aller au cirque c'est un kiffe
pour tout le monde c'est vraiment c'est
une des sorties voilà la familiale les
les plus puissantes voilà on va pas se
mentir et là on est dans une société je
vous le dis et après je vais te laisser
parler parce que je te dis je te mets je
te voilà je te fais introduction mais où
on veut tout arrêter ça veut dire le
cirque on veut plus et faites foraine on
veut plus on peut plus rien faire ça
veut dire que maintenant c'est un truc
de fou donc il faut protéger tout le
monde non protégeant tout le monde on
met encore plus de gens dans la merde je
vous le dis et il y a plein de potes à
moi des forains et des gars du cirque et
des gars du voyage qui sont dans la
merde je vous le dis ils étaient ils
sont là ils veulent faire leur travail
et ils peuvent plus le faire parce que
ils ont des milliers d'associations sur
le dos c'est dans dis-nous ce qui se
passe actuellement sur Loïc donc
aujourd'hui on est quand même victime de
moi j'ai voyagé en Europe
avec mon cirque et actuellement on est
le seul pays d'Europe où les cirques ont
autant de problèmes c'est parce
qu'aujourd'hui
les élus de la République pour lequel la
population les a mis en place mais ils
veulent plus de gens itinérants c'est ça
c'est tout simplement parce qu'on rentre
pas dans des cases et comme on rentre
pas dans ces cases et ben ça les dérange
et comme ça les dérange et ben nous
interdit de vivre alors donc faut quand
même pas oublier que dans notre pays en
France la liberté d'aller venir elle
fait partie de notre Constitution donc
on peut pas nous empêcher aujourd'hui
pour demain prendre une loi pour dire
ces gens-là ont plus le droit d'aller
vivre alors on a face à nous comme on
voit sur les images derrière des élus de
la République qui veulent aller au
dessus des lois donc faut quand même pas
oublier que un cirque ou une fête
foraine où tout le spectacle itinérant
que ça soit des expositions de
dinosaures des Monster Truck tout ça ces
établissements là sont réglementés par
l'État nous avons des cahiers des
charges à respecter nous avons obligé
d'avoir des agréments de l'État donc nos
entreprises sont légiférées par l'État
et en face vous avez des cowboys comme
là on moi sur les images un élu qui va
la provocation d'un patron de cirque qui
qui au bout du rouleau qui pète un câble
parce que ben il en a marre il a des
enfants on est d'accord et et je suis le
premier à le défendre ton pote parce que
voilà j'espère qu'il aura demain juste
il a été un peu comme moi il a été un
peu loin on est d'accord mais je
cautionne pas les paroles cautionne pas
voilà tous les deux semaines après je
donne pas raison à la famille Muller
d'insulter un élu de la République parce
que c'est pas logique je ne peux pas
être d'accord avec ça je suis direct
avec toi Cyril parce que moi
il a été trop loin mais il est formé le
fond voilà c'est ça mais si vous
regardez bien les images pourquoi
pourquoi on laisse cet élu avant c'est
toujours sur le mec alors qu'il y a des
forces de l'ordre qui sont là pour
calmer la situation et le faire reculer
pour arrêter qui est s'affront pas entre
deux personnes après après le gars il
veut discuter après voilà c'est vrai que
les mots étaient quittés
voilà c'est ça je suis d'accord avec toi
ça voilà ça on est d'accord après quelle
est l'histoire pour nos téléspectateurs
on va remonter la vidéo dans un instant
qui a été vu des milliers de fois qui
c'est quoi l'histoire alors l'histoire
ça tourne essentiellement quand même
autour des animaux alors qu'il y a une
loi qui s'appliquera définitivement et
vraiment de manière très contraignante
en 208 qui est empêchera les cirques
d'avoir des animaux pour le moment les
cirques peuvent encore avoir des animaux
mais plus les utiliser dans les
représentations et c'est très compliqué
pour laisser comment et ben justement
ils ont les animaux vous pouvez les voir
par exemple ah non non c'est pas
interdit de les présenter monsieur c'est
ce que je dis vous pouvez aller voir
actuellement à les numéros les numéros
les numéros et c'est un hippopotame là
vous pouvez la loi les formelles je fais
partie de la commission est terminée ce
siège au ministère de l'Intérieur et
également de dans les ministères comme
la transition écologique et tous les
ministères pour lequel on dépend dépend
de du ministère un point cirque donc
pour vous dire aujourd'hui le projet de
loi a été adopté c'est un projet oui
aujourd'hui personne peut le mettre en
place même l'état aujourd'hui nos prix
aucun des cris d'application personne
peut aujourd'hui le mettre en place
pourquoi parce que déjà premièrement
pour interdire il faut déjà de l'argent
bon il y en a pas donc faut déjà nous
indemniser à nous pour le préjudice
moral qu'on va subir le préjudice
culturel le patrimoine de nos ancêtres
moi dans ma famille on fait du cirque
depuis 1857 et aujourd'hui on veut
arrêter mon histoire moi j'ai 55 ans
j'ai 55 ans j'ai quatre filles j'ai
trois petits enfants et on est tous dans
le cirque donc pour revenir sur la loi
la loi la loi aujourd'hui attendez une
fois la loi la loi aujourd'hui qu'est-ce
qu'il est écrit il est écrit qu'il y a
un projet qui dit qu'en 2028 en novembre
2028 il y a une loi qui est prévue pour
interdire les cirques itinérants de
présenter des animaux spectacle
aujourd'hui rien ne l'interdit rien la
loi ne l'interdit pas c'était quoi son
problème parce que il parle il parle de
jumboard
alors il dit qu'il était sous le soleil
pendant 3 heures c'est quoi
[Musique]
ils ne veulent plus des cirques voilà
ils ne veulent plus que les cirques
s'installe on leur a refusé
l'installation et l'élu dit mais ils
nous ont piégé en sollicitant de manière
frauduleuse une installation est-ce que
vous êtes d'accord avec ça voilà en
disant on se faisant passer pour
quelqu'un téléphoner en faisant passer
pour quelqu'un pour pour avoir ce
terrain privé pour s'installer sur ce
terrain voilà nous avons le passé nous
sommes la mairie nous avons ils se sont
fait passer pour quelqu'un et pas pour
un cirque ils ont pas dit que c'était un
cirque on va s'installer là ils ont
sollicité
il faut juste comprendre je vous dis je
suis Emmanuel Macron monsieur je vous
envoie quelqu'un vous me donnez tout
votre pognon vous le donner sans
contrôler
votre vie vous me donnez tout sur un
cousine donc c'est quand même une
institution le cirque a fait la demande
il a donné son numéro de régime de
commerce il est marqué sur l'autor
isation comment ils ont dit non
quand il a fait la demande ils l'ont
donné ils ont dit non ils se donnent non
mais quand il a l'autorisation qu'il a
de de l'habitat là où le mec comment il
s'appelle la grand-mère
Patrick je sais pas
Anthony Boré
Anthony Boré il est le
combien de temps
Patrick
alors le premier avion maire de Nice il
fait son boulot alors donc oui mais oui
mais si il fait son boulot Cindy qui est
notre autorisation frauduleuse s'il le
dit pourquoi ils l'ont pas contrôlé et à
ce moment-là et ben faites une procédure
et à l'autre tribunal pour moi il y a
une plante on verra ce que le tribunal
dira aujourd'hui condamner quelqu'un
sans l'avoir jugé pour moi c'est pas
possible il faut déjà attendre un
jugement donc là est-ce qu'il va y avoir
le cirque ce cirque alors il est parti
de cette place là parce que le préfet a
trouvé un emplacement pour les mettre à
Antibes sauf que le maire d'Antibes
comme il a dit Monsieur toute la
métropole moi je suis allé à Nice ça
fait plus de 10 ans j'ai été je me suis
installé plat esplanade de Lattre de
Tassigny bon j'ai ma famille qui tourne
là-bas qui sont aussi des cirques qui
allaient avant les cirques étaient
toujours les bienvenus à Nice
aujourd'hui estrosier toute sa compagnie
autour veulent plus aucun cirque sur la
la Côte d'Azur les cirques alors ce qui
est un peu dans le match et ben allez
leur demander pourquoi ils vous disent
que c'est les animaux c'est un prétexte
vous leur dites que vous amenez un
cirque sans animaux ils vous autorise
pas vous pour une exposition de
dinosaures ils veulent pas vous leur
demandez pour des Monster Trucks qui
veulent pas non plus donc tout ce qui
est lié au problème avec les tout ce qui
est bien itinérance
pourquoi ben parce qu'ils veulent plus
qu'on voyage ils veulent nous mettre
dans des cases donc ils veulent ils
veulent alors c'est pas la première fois
il y a une ville dans
l'heure donc voyez c'est pas les cirques
et les animaux c'est vraiment les gens
qui sont itinérants qui sont bien sûr
stigmatisés parce qu'on vit dans des
caravanes mais pourquoi ils font ça si
c'est juste si populaire chez les gens
en fait pourquoi ils suivent pas parce
que un élu dans une ville si demanderait
à la population est-ce que vous voulez
voir un cirque ou pas il prendrait la
décision à ce sujet là moi je dirais bon
les gens veulent pas le voir il vient
pas c'est une chose le seul problème
qu'il y a c'est quand vous vous
installez dans une ville le public est
là donc les gens quand on leur dise
c'est le maire qui veut pas comment ça
le maire il veut pas de ciel et nous nos
gosses alors les gens ils la fête
foraine c'est pareil donc ils se disent
je suis un élu je suis le patron je fais
ce que je veux dans ma ville non parce
que la ville elle appartient pas au
maire à la partie au peuple français
ministres lui il est juste un il a juste
la gestion du domaine public donc
comment un maire peut interdire des gens
de bosser aujourd'hui il y a du mal pour
tout le monde alors et nous on nous
interdit de travailler c'est pas normal
donc c'est pas c'est la dernière fois et
c'était un peu embrouillé avec le maire
de Nice aussi
mais bien sûr mais écoutez Cyril moi
aussi je m'installe illégalement dans
des villes quand on n'arrive pas à voir
d'autorisation on est obligé de
travailler on a des enfants vous voyez
là j'étais à Orléans en l'espace
chapiteau on a quitté l'espace chapiteau
on devait aller dans une ville ça a pas
été on a été dans une autre ville on a
été reçu quand même par un particulier
mais notre vie de saltimbanque d'aller
de ville en ville c'est une croyez moi
on a une belle vie parce que on est
libre mais notre liberté
on peut pas on continue à vivre comme ça
alors il se plaignent que l'État fait
rien avant l'état fait pas rien l'état
fait pas rien parce que nous en tant que
syndicat on a demandé à l'état de
prendre des décrets de faire des
circulaires pour faciliter le dialogue
entre nous et les élus pour leur prouver
qu'on n'est pas des bêtes noires et
qu'on n'est pas des parias on vient pour
travailler et donc il se plaignent les
élus disent ah oui mais l'état fait rien
ils expulse pas les cirques ouais mais
de quel droit vous nous interdisez de
travailler l'interdiction général est
absolue est interdite par la loi alors
on fait quoi nous alors il specte de
l'État mais vous en tant qu'élu respecté
aussi les lois alors ce qui a un maire
qui veut pas de cirque avec animaux
alors que la loi de l'encadre et de
l'aut orise pourquoi lui respecte pas la
loi alors on va voir regarde ce qui est
une embrouille avec Christian Estrosi
aussi
on
peut partir
maintenant donnez-nous une solution une
solution travail alors
bon
il y a le gars qui me dit dans
l'oreillette et qu'est-ce qu'il est
constitué il est nerveux quand même
moi je trouve qu'il y a une grosse
hypocrisie autour de 6 sortes de
bien-être animal je pense qu'ils en ont
rien à [__] la vérité c'est qu'on sent
bien qu'il y a une sorte de mépris
social ils vont passer pour des sauvages
vous les dérangez c'est quoi vous leur
faites peur en fait bah vous savez ce
qu'il cherche quand il vient dans
l'affrontement comme ça comme ils savent
qu'on est des gens qu'on va pas dans les
tribunaux pour régler nos problèmes nous
on les règlements donc ils veulent qu'on
aille au clash pourquoi garde à vue
condamnation pour avoir tapé sur un élu
mais on est quand même pas swing on va
pas l'élever la main sur un élu parce
qu'on respecte quand même certaines
personnes nous ce qu'on respecte pas
c'est leur vision d'imposer une loi dans
une collectivité qui date leurs
appartient pas qu'à partir au peuple
français autant à nous on paye des
charges sociales on est comme tout le
monde on est des entreprises et
aujourd'hui Monsieur Estrosi que je
respecte qui vient du monde forain parce
que faut savoir que le maire de Nice
c'est grand-parents sont des forains et
pour quelle raison il est contre tout ce
qu'il y a il veut Inter normalement 2024
il y aura plus de fête foraine à Nice
c'est quand même pas normal avec tout
nous enlever il va nous enlever
un truc à te dire quand même qui est
important parce que les gens disent on
peut se réinventer faire du Cirque
autrement alors je vais venir sur un
sujet que pas beaucoup de gens ont parlé
ni très peu de médias le cirque le
flambeau des cirques français qui devait
faire l'écossir qu'en vrai Joseph
Bouglione et Ben a fait faillite il a
déposé le bilan l'année dernière il a
été vendu aux enchères pour des
clopinettes donc le cirque sans animaux
ça peut peut-être marcher mais
aujourd'hui on a des enfants et des
parents qui veulent et nous on les fait
rêver encore et c'est ce qui nous donne
notre force de combattre aujourd'hui les
les élus pour leur démontrer que les
gens veulent encore voir du siècle en a
fait cinq semaines à Orléans et cinq
semaines de cirque était quasiment plein
chez spectacle alors on va revoir cette
vidéo qui a fait énormément parler si
vous nous rejoignez c'est une
altercation très violente qui relance le
vieux débat de la présence des cirques
dans les villes dans les Alpes-Maritimes
les dirigeants d'un cirque le premier
adjoint au maire de Nice se sont
insultés très copieusement alors que les
autorités regarde
[Rires]
au soleil dans un camion qu'est-ce que
ça promet
je te dis allez c'est bon c'est parti je
te dis je rigole doucement doucement
c'était pour dire je t'en fous de [__]
il va monter en l'air enfant de [__]
on est tous d'accord pour dire qu'il a
été loin avec Anthony Boré
dans le panneau c'est une sorte de
manipulation ils vont sur place pour les
provoquer pour les titilles l'intimide
un peu il filme on sait qu'il va partir
il sort des mots qui sont voilà qui sont
pas très politiquement correct
évidemment qu'il ne pense pas
textuellement mais il ne pense pas
textuellement ce qu'il dit quand il dit
[__] c'est pas une insulte homophobe
envers cette élu c'est parce qu'il est
énervé il est sous le coup de la colère
mais c'est une manipulation pour montrer
que non mais c'est une manipulation pour
montrer que soi-disant ces gens ne sont
pas fréquentables et qui n'ont pas leur
place dans la société et ils se fait
avoir bêtement et c'est dégueulasse je
trouve ça dégueulasse en terme de comme
il y a aucun débat d'idées en fait moi
je pense que c'est dommage parce qu'ils
viennent à 30 policiers 30 flics
sur quand on voit avec Monsieur Estrosi
ils étaient pas trois il y a plein de
camions il y a excuse-moi de te couper
il y avait six cartes CRS 6 cartes CRS
c'est pas trois ils viennent pas jusqu'à
22h du soir 3 ils viennent à plusieurs
ils font dégoupiller un mec qui est là
pour gagner sa vie à qui on interdit de
travailler parce que pour des pour des
excuses de je sais pas quoi les gens
veulent plus voir ceux-ci veulent plus
voir cela mais en attendant comme il a
dit ils viennent pas dans ces places là
pour perdre de l'argent s'ils viennent
là c'est bien qu'il gagne de l'argent
c'est bien qu'il y a des gens qui leur
donnent l'argent c'est bien que ça plaît
aux gens s'appelait aux enfants
c'est un kiffe on veut les tuer juste
dès qu'ils sont élus comme il a dit dès
qu'ils sont Ulysse permettent tous et
puis ils veulent pas parce que pourquoi
ça fait Gilles pourquoi ils veulent pas
en fait c'est essentiellement la
maltraitance animale il faut parler
avec les enfants c'est quoi les
la vérité et là et là je rejoins Raymond
à fond ils font la même chose avec les
fêtes foraines pas des animaux dans le
bateau pirate frère
dans le train fantôme tu as pas tu as
pas une hyène qui vient de caresser les
yeux le problème c'est un prétexte le
problème
on juge on juge que les 800 animaux qui
sont utilisés donc tu parles pas
d'animaux
[Musique]
mais ils viennent avec une fête foraine
ça aurait été pareil
à chaque fois on le sait est-ce que les
fêtes foraines c'est autorisées
l'année prochaine la fête voilà donc il
y a des animaux dans le bateau pirate
Vernon il y a pas assez
il y a pas de problème c'est quoi le
problème dans le mais c'est les animaux
les profil des animaux
c'est que si c'est le sujet vraiment
vous savez qu'ils veulent pas nous
l'écrire voir sur blanc qui veulent pas
de cire qui est animaux parce que quand
on les met au tribunal ils perdent bien
sûr donc ah ben oui parce que quand vous
en envoie admettons pour un cirque comme
moi j'envoie 5 6 en courrier par an tu
as demandé des villes nous sommes au
regret de ne pouvoir répondre
favorablement votre requête mais c'est
tout c'est un courrier type quand vous
voulez plus loin dans les débats vous
leur dites écoutez pourquoi vous voulez
pas accueillir cirque alors au téléphone
il nous disent parce que on veut plus
prendre de cirque parce que vous savez
des mentalités changent on va aller plus
loin que la loi on souhaite répu
accueillir cirque avec animaux vous
pouvez nous l'écrire ah non on peut pas
le décrire et pour moi juste parce que
quand quand vous faites
moi j'ai fait des actions de justice
contre des villes notamment je vais vous
dire où j'ai pas honte à le dire au
Vésinet j'ai mis la ville au tribunal et
le tribunal m'a donné et le maire a été
obligé de m'accueillir dans sa ville
parce que quand vous faites une
procédure et que vous gagnez et bien il
a pas le choix il est obligé de vous
donner parce que c'est annulation du
refus donc qui vous donne autorisation
c'est cette tactique donc les animaux
alors Gilles Verdez juste Gilles toi tu
es pour les cirques mais sans animaux je
pense qu'il faut arrêter les arrêts mais
comment tu fais et ben il faut que
l'État qu'on pense mais c'est ce que
l'État va faire elle était dis-moi voilà
maltraitance
dis-moi eh déjà non non mais déjà qui
s'occupe des des Français
le 11 du mois avant de s'occupe avant de
donner de l'argent aussi qu'on va donner
des milliards au cirque alors qu'il y a
des Français qui sont dans la merde
arrête de dire des conneries et que nous
on demande rien à un moment tu peux pas
aider tout le monde il y a des priorités
arrête de dire des conneries tous et
vous leur marche sur la tête lui c'est
que l'État attends tu veux que l'état
donne de l'argent à des mecs alors que
ils veulent donner de la TVA à l'état
c'est l'inverse eux ils veulent faire
travailler l'argent
monsieur la maltraitance animale c'est
quoi pour vous des animaux sauvages ou
venus d'endroits sauvages qui sont
utilisés dans des cirques ça pour moi
c'est de la maltraitance
[Musique]
est-ce que vous savez qu'est-ce que
c'est le médical training c'est quoi non
vous allez m'expliquer bon alors
training alors les eaux ont changé le
nom en anglais parce que ça passe mieux
aux oreilles les os les os les hommes
les oreillers
[Rires]
le mot dressage en médical training
parce que dans elles ont ils sont
obligés d'adresser les animaux pour leur
faire des soins donc couche-toi donne la
patte lève-toi vais te faire une prise
de sang ceci cela c'est de l'éducation
monsieur couche-toi donne la et nous et
nous on fait pareil comme vous regardez
que ça soit n'importe quel zoo en Franck
n'importe quel parc zoologique dans le
monde l'éléphant il apprenne à lever la
pâte pour donner la patte il la prend à
se coucher pour lui faire des prises de
sang et donc c'est quand même du
dressage monsieur indirectement j'ai une
question monsieur est-ce que puisque
vous dites qu'effectivement en 2028 il
va y avoir ce décret qui pourrait
éventuellement passer on est en 2023
est-ce que entre 2023 et 2028 vous avez
pas le temps justement de faire évoluer
votre cirque
le problème qu'il y a madame je vous
explique déjà c'est des animaux qu'ils
ont l'habitude à cette villa aujourd'hui
si demain on leur enlève je
sais pas si vous faites du sport non pas
bon les gens qui font du sport
une activité ludique chaque jour un
animal de cirque quand il est éduqué
parce que maintenant les dressent plus
parce qu'il faut savoir que pour éduquer
un animal de cirque maintenant on a des
figures qu'on a plus le droit de faire
ça nous est interdit par le cahier des
charges on doit faire avec les animaux
que des figures qui sont naturelles et
donc c'est à dire on respecte ça bien et
on est obligé parce que les agréments
que nous avons de l'État il faut quand
même savoir qu'on est le seul pays
d'Europe où il y avait une législation
où les animaux étaient encadrés qui
étaient identifiés et pour lequel que
pour les détenir il fallait respecter
certaines critères aujourd'hui ces
animaux alors ça fait comme je vais
finir là-dessus alors donc ça veut dire
que ça fait 40 ans
que l'État laisse maltraiter des animaux
alors parce que c'est eux qui ont mis en
place un cahier des charges et
aujourd'hui il y a des petits bisounours
qui sont arrivés ils ont dit ah bah
tiens les cirques qui maltraitent les
animaux parce qu'ils sont cage mais là
ils sont aussi dans des cages d'un zoo
derrière ça c'est des parties qu'ils ont
des cages en fixe parce que nous on n'a
pas de cage en fixe ça c'est un parc
zoologique donc dans un parc zoologique
les animaux sont aussi dans des cages
ils sont dans des parcs et les animaux
ah ça c'est pas une remorque derrière
c'est un mur ça c'est des murs tu vois
c'est des parpaings
[Musique]
peut-être en fixe ça qui avait des cages
avec des installations mais il faut
savoir que les animaux de zoo pourquoi
ils ont mis maintenant des jouets pour
les amuser tout ça parce que les animaux
mourraient d'ennuis nous ils ont pas
d'ennuis chez nous parce que les animaux
changent de ville ça c'est quoi ça par
exemple ça c'est pas en France ça c'est
pas non mais ça c'est pas en France la
faut le dire il y a pas un cirque qui a
des ours en France aucun cirque en
France
en France c'est très contrôlée
moi je dénonce ça des gens qui font ça
faut qu'ils soient condamnés
déjà mais c'est normal moi je suis pour
la loi et la justice si quelqu'un
maltraite un animal il doit être
condamné par les services de l'État
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
pour terminer là-dessus
dans la cage
[Rires]
astrologique lion et moi je suis cancer
va très bien ce love merci d'avoir été
avec nous je voudrais dire un truc et je
te le dis Gilou tu sais comme je t'aime
je t'explique les mecs dans les villes
le seul truc qui vole pas ils se disent
ils veulent pas qu'ils viennent c'est
pas pour les animaux c'est du mytho mais
total je te le dis c'est juste parce que
il se dit ça va [__] le bordel un truc
et ça [__] le bordel dans la vie c'est
tout ce qui se passe et il dit ça va
mobiliser des forces de l'ordre ça va
mobiliser des trucs c'est tout je te le
dis arrête de nous prendre tous ces
formes de discrimination
2 minutes voilà c'est tout ce que je
demande arrêtez de nous prendre pour des
cons dites alors la vérité moi je
préfère un mec qui la vérité exactement
je préfère la mère et dit écoute-moi
bien j'ai pas envie tu vas me [__] le
bordel j'ai pas envie allez merci voilà
merci alors je préfère un mec comme ça
voilà je te le dis merci en tout cas
d'avoir été là on a un sondage on a plus
rien enfin très bien et ben on a un
sondage ça va très bien comprenez-vous
la colère non alors voilà bah tu vois
47 52
[Rires]
c'est un bon truc ça c'est passé un bon
truc bah c'est bon